en el norte de la región de París los
habitantes se han refrescado en piscinas
al aire libre algunos han acudido a la
playa de la comuna en la región se
alcanzaron máximas de 40 grados del
martes los adultos han vigilado a los
niños jugando
eso están sufriendo mucho con la ola de
calor pueden deshidratarse rápidamente
Así que aumentos como éste son muy
importantes
mientras uno se divierten otros trabajan
en las obras las tareas de los
trabajadores son aún más difíciles por
las altas temperaturas como aquí al este
del país en Lyon
estamos sudando y sufriendo estamos
bebiendo mucha agua
este obrero independiente no tiene más
remedio que trabajar solo a pesar del
calor aquí estoy poniendo las baldosas
el pegante pega más rápido de lo normal
Las Juntas son las mismas Y eso
dificulta las cosas en un negocio hay
facturas que se acumulan constantemente
Así que hay que cumplir hay que trabajar
trabajar trabajar trabajar trabajar
trabajar
otra parte la población vulnerable Al
Calor son los niños pequeños
esta guardería de la ciudad de wong fue
equipada con aire acondicionado no son
capaces de decirme cuando tienen
demasiado calor Así que debemos
vigilarlos para poder hidratarlos
adecuadamente ya sea rociandolos con
agua o rehidratándolos la alerta naranja
por ola de calor se mantuvo durante todo
el martes en 70 departamentos franceses
ya que se esperan tormentas en todo el
país de norte a sur